hi everyone i'm saad omar i'm the
director of the yale institute for
global health i'm really delighted to
welcome you to the global health
conversation series uh in addition to
the yale institute for global health or
ygh the series is co-sponsored by the
walker fund at the macmillan center at
yale
well a lot of you probably know that
eradication of disease is defined as a
deliberate
set of efforts
towards a permanent reduction to zero of
the worldwide incidence of infection
caused by a specific agent
the eradication efforts require
enormous planning and effort and
implementation and dedication
uh the eradication of smallpox uh the
the only human disease that has been
eradicated so far uh was spearheaded by
the smallpox eradication program
launched by the world health
organization in 1976
this multiple initiative focused on
endemic countries
and utilized a combination of
surveillance case finding contact
tracing ring vaccination
and communication campaigns to inform
affected population
uh fueled by uh
worldwide support by 1973
the number of countries with a smallpox
had substantially decreased with the
last infection reported in somalia on
october 26 1977
so who teams search for possible small
fox infections in the next couple of
years finding no further cases and at
the 23rd
world health assembly in 1980 so
approximately um
42 years ago smallpox was officially
deemed eradicated
uh to reflect this momentous effort and
and um
to discuss eradication in the context of
the present and future and the future
i'm so pleased to have with us dr
william feige or dr bill feige the
former chief chief for smallpox
eradication program and a former
director of the cdc uh between
1977 and 1983.
as in his leadership role within the
smallpox eradication program dr feige
pioneered the technique known as the
surveillance containment
developed to combat spread of smallpox
in the face of vaccine shortages so uh
it was you know public health is about
uh you know life giving you lemons and
making lemonade that was one useful
lemonade that helped us eradicate and
this was a combination of both
theoretical understanding of what was
going on but also applied public health
and i remain as an infectious disease
epidemiologist i i remain a fan of that
approach that that was very suitable for
that disease
and and so using this method dr feige
and his team was able to uh were able to
play a major role in eradicating an
infectious disease for the first time in
human
history
uh subsequently and that was just um you
know i think it's reasonable to say no
because we know the rest of the story
that was at the start of his career if
you will if if you look at the full
trajectory um he then went on to be
a legendary cdc director in 77
where he served for six years uh he
co-founded the task force for uh child
survival and development
now known as task force for global
health played a major role in the
development and evolution of the carter
center uh provided invaluable advice at
the beginning and the foundation of the
gates foundation
and so on and so forth he he remains a
professor
emeritus at emory and personally
speaking uh one of the proudest things
in my career for me personally
was to be the second ever bill feige
professor
at emory and so that was an incredible
honor and and as an aside when i would
teach my class and and dr feige would
lecture in that on smallpox first of all
what i get for a vaccine class
we would have he would be the only
lecturer
uh lecturer you know who would have his
own fan base in class and there would be
a line
uh for people taking
you know initially old school photos but
incl increasing his selfies with him uh
and and getting uh
his book signed copies of his book
signed
one of the
most um
remarkable thing about bill figgy is
that he's not only a scientist
but he is if you if i could say so the
original of the original social justice
warriors in the sense
focusing on
equity
as part of the core dna of public health
and global health before it was uh
before we had labels around these issues
and so it is my pleasure and honor uh to
talk to him
uh about smallpox eradication but also
having a forward-looking discussion of
what are the implications
on future eradication have efforts
future global health and public health
efforts and what are some of the lessons
um you know us mere mortals can can
learn from uh a giants like uh dr feige
so welcome dr feige
thanks son thanks for having me uh
thanks for being a professor at emory
thanks for bringing some glitter to my
name
and uh it's good to be on this program
my pleasure so
the first question is simple
is eradication worth it
let me divide that into two things one
has to do with people and the other with
money
for people
think of the fact that w.h.o said in the
20th century 300 million people died of
smallpox
since most all of them died in the first
75 years that means there were 4 million
deaths a year
and that
is
about as high as any disease i mean
tuberculosis and measles were in that
category but four million deaths a year
plus four million people scarred for
life
and so uh
from the personal point of view it's
worth it
then you look at the money
and it's said that it cost about 300
million dollars to eradicate
smallpox half of this came from the
united states well the united states has
recouped its investment
every three months
because of what it used to cost to treat
people who had complications
because of the vaccine who are died or
the
fact that we had to have quarantine so
since smallpox has been eradicated
we have recouped our investment
130 times every dollar
that was invested has come back with 130
so yes uh it's worth it in many ways we
borrow from our children and when you
look at climate change and what we've
done to the plastic in the ocean and so
forth
we're depending on our children and
grandchildren to pay that off well
disease eradication is one way that we
pay forward and we actually give a gift
to our grandchildren so yes it's worth
it
wonderful um so
you know um we know and those of us who
have read your
sort of writings about it you know so
smallpox eradication
ran into roadblocks uh roadblocks um and
had
areas of efficiency
so how many of those roadblocks or
positive aspects are applicable in the
current day
are there any new difficulties or new
challenges or areas that have improved
um since smallpox was eradicated
i think every day during the smallpox
eradication program was a
problem-solving day and we looked for
people that had a record of being
problem solvers
so
uh in two in 2020 we expected to have a
meeting in atlanta to celebrate 40 years
since the who declaration
and as part of that we were looking at
what are the positive lessons that we
learned from small blocks then the
pandemic came along we could not have
that meeting
so instead we continued to work on what
are the lessons learned and could we put
them into a curriculum which we've done
under the
umbrella of becoming better ancestors
that would actually have something to
say for today and tomorrow so it so
happened that we were looking at these
lessons during the coronavirus pandemic
and it i'm just going to go through the
the nine lessons we focused on very
quickly
to show you the the difference between
smallpox and coronavirus number one
lesson is this is a cause and effect
world and stephen hawking says this in
his book a short history of time
that the whole history of science is the
gradual realization that things do not
happen in an arbitrary way it's a cause
and effect world
and so on coronavirus we have a
president that says it's going to
disappear like magic
then a second lesson is you have to know
the truth and there were times when we
did not want to know the truth and i
remember october of 1973 our first
village to village search in india
and in just two states we found 10 000
new cases of smallpox that no one knew
existed
in just six days time and some people
said let's never do this again
but of course you have to do it again
it's the best surveillance you you've
ever had so there are many times you
don't want the truth but you need the
truth in order to continue but a third
lesson is you don't do anything alone it
requires coalitions
so in this country
we should have had for coronavirus a
coalition that went from national level
that said here are some guidelines and
you can change these in states and
cities and counties as you need to but
instead
our government said to the states you're
all on your own so compete
figure out this on your own and compete
for resources
the the next lesson that we learned
was avoid certainty and richard feynman
the physicist said
physics is the most certain of sciences
and it's uncertain and he said certainty
is the achilles heel
of science and of course it is of
politics and religion and everything
else
but we had so much certainty given by
various people
at press conferences on coronavirus the
fifth lesson
you have to continuously evaluate and
change what you're doing
in india this meant we had a meeting
every month in endemic states to find
out what worked last month what didn't
work how do we change our tactics the
next month
and
in in this country with coronavirus we
didn't have that kind of evaluation and
and changing of what was happening a
sixth lesson respect the culture
and we know that if you go in with your
ideas of how to do things
culture will always win
so if you tangle with culture culture
will win you have to respect it from the
beginning
the next lesson was the
trade-off between science and management
the best decisions come from the best
science the best results come from the
best management so how do you put
science and management together
the eighth
lesson
you need political support
and this just becomes absolutely
essential that you have politics
involved and many people have concluded
after coronavirus we don't want
politicians involved
in public health that's absolutely the
wrong conclusion
that it's the politicians that decide on
the money that we get we need them to
help solve the problems become part of
the solution to be invested in the
solution rather than saying we want to
separate ourselves from them and the
last lesson is no matter where you live
you're both global and local
and so wherever you're practicing public
health you're practicing global public
health
and the objective of global public
health is global health equity
so everyone in public health is working
on global health equity well
no one in public health even
imagined in the midst of a pandemic that
we would leave who
so all of this is to show how the
lessons that we learned from smallpox
were ignored which leads to the 10th the
last lesson
lessons are useless if ignored
now that's no
very insightful and
you know
a couple of things specifically strike
me
uh you know you can't publi you have to
engage
uh our elected leaders uh especially in
democracies even otherwise but it
doesn't have to be partisan so political
doesn't have to be partisan and you've
shown like you you
and and several other leaders have been
well respected
on both sides of the aisle
and
have been able to make the case for
public health which is obviously harder
because as you have often said
uh you know public health is effective
and nothing happens um and so so
therefore
um you know it is challenging but but i
think it's uh doable so switching gears
a little bit cdc has identified the
virus that causes
smallpox as um
as a potential bioterrorism threat
in a changing world
where biological capacity
is increasingly available beyond a few
specialized labs
and there are
perverse incentives for state and
non-state actors
to
engage in activities that are not
necessarily ethical
how do we reduce and mitigate or you
know even eliminate the risk
i think bioterrorism with smallpox fires
has been a concern right from the
beginning
and
particularly before the united states
invaded iraq
and there were questions about did iraq
have
the virus and were they using it for
research on bioterrorism
and in fact there was a
a story front page of the new york times
saying they did have the virus that had
been provided to them by russia
and that it was a virus that could not
you could not protect against with our
current vaccine
well the administration came up with a
plan to first vaccinate first responders
then they would go to 10 million beyond
that and then there the question was
would they go to the whole population or
not
the institute of medicine was asked to
oversee that program
and i was asked to be a member of it but
i was told that we could not produce a
report that criticized the
administration
i was taken back by that
and i said well i can't be part of it
then
later they came and they asked if i
would be a consultant
if i was not able to vote or anything
and then i could say anything i wanted
and so i did do an op-ed piece for the
washington post and pointed out
if it's true
that they have a virus that you cannot
protect against with vaccine why are we
spending so much attention on
vaccination in this country
and number two
why don't we realize that if there's a
case
the problem in the united states will be
panic
it won't be the disease itself it'll be
the panic
and the plan was that they could get to
10 million people
in 10 days of vaccination
i said if there were cases we would have
300 million people trying to get in that
line of 10 million
and it's the panic that would cause the
problem
i proposed a solution to cdc and they
didn't accept it
and so i simply put it as a one-page
summary
in my book on house on fire
which is very simple that you look at
the 3 000 counties as the point at which
we would respond to small bucks
we would in each county use the high
schools as the point of vaccination
it's very easy to
to estimate how many people live in the
catchment area of a high school
if you could tell the entire country if
need be
we could vaccinate everyone in three
days time and that would prevent the
next cases of smallpox you could prevent
the panic
you can train people in 10 minutes to do
vaccination with a bifurcated needle
so we would know how many vaccinators we
would need and we would get nurses we'd
get teachers we could volunteers and
retired people so you could line all
this up in advance
you could keep the vaccine at a national
level and send it out overnight to 3 000
counties if you had to
and once you can assure the country
everyone could be vaccinated in three to
three days time you take away the panic
factor
now it's it's relatively easy to do that
with smallpox it's much more complicated
to do this with other agents
but
we could we weren't even
even able to come up with a reasonable
response to smallpox so you can see the
difficulties of a response to other
problems
no that's you know that's an interesting
uh
you know point that you highlighted
um that you know things vary by by
pathogen uh but also that there are
things
that you can do even about panic and
sometimes we
um are paralyzed by by the potential
fear of uh public reaction
where we often forget uh the basic
principles of public health and public
health communication
well sort of you know in in
in every other
school of public health or in every
school of public health um
there is a discussion um in every
semester about the value of vertical
versus horizontal programs
uh
you led one of the most vertical
programs and then have worked on
enhancing some of the most horizontal
programs
et cetera so so you know um
what are the implications of of vertical
disease-specific programs versus
um you know horizontal programs and
their impact on primary healthcare
so you can put vertical versus
horizontal on any program and get people
gathering in a room because there are
strong feelings on both sides
and i
came to a conclusion in the 19
when i was uh
president of the american public health
association for a year and had to give
the keynote address
and so i decided to go back a hundred
years to see what they were discussing
100 years earlier at apha
and to my total surprise i found that
the discussion was vertical versus
horizontal i thought that that was a
fairly recent global health discussion
and here it went back 100 years so i
said to myself well in a hundred years
what happened in this country
and it was very clear every time we had
a tool
we used it
which is vertical and every time we use
it we improved the infrastructure
which was horizontal
and that made it easier to take the next
tool and include it so it was always a
ratcheting up a vertical horizontal
vertical horizontal and so there should
be no discussion of which is best
they're both needed
and uh
so
we have to actually educate people in
how to make that happen so that this
doesn't become the argument
yeah no you're right and sometimes it's
presented as a kind of a false choice
um so
switching gears a little bit again and
and what happens some salient
um you know for lack of
failures
and successes and triumphs in the covert
19 pandemic
it really was a triumphant tragedy
the tragedy i've just pointed out with
the nine lessons that were ignored the
triumph is
look at what happened with vaccines
i went back in my journal and found that
the first note i ever made
on messenger rna was 25 years ago after
hearing a lecture
and i wondered what would happen after
that so you see how long people have
been working on that
for much of the public they think that
the work was
just in the last year or two or three
and here it's been going on all the time
this was the triumph
of coronavirus a vaccine that came
online so fast where you had government
support
and
the other part of this triumph is you
know we have
for the last 30 years
averaged about one new
disease problem a year
each time
we get excited about it we get funds and
we think this is finally going to change
the infrastructure of public health
and we are soon going to reach the same
level as
fire stations
that is
if a fire station
and an airport doesn't have a disaster
for 10 years no one wants to reduce
their budget
everyone understands you have to keep
funding it so we always think that's
what's going to happen in public health
we'll get an infrastructure that is
solid and continues on
and it never happens
i thought with coronavirus for sure this
is going to happen i no longer believe
that that's going to happen and we have
to figure out how to make that actually
happen so that it's part of the triumph
of coronavirus
yeah
so in terms of
the premier public health agency in [ __ ]
in this country the cdc
what should the cdc look like after this
pandemic is under control more you know
while obviously
it will take some time to bring the
pandemic fully under control we can
start now so what what should be the
future of the cdc
but there are three or four things that
i think of
you notice that the field of public
health has continued to increase it was
pretty much infectious diseases when i
started
uh and became interested in this 70
years ago
but it's then gone from occupational
health to environmental health to
chronic diseases to
violence and injury
it keeps increasing
we still have a couple of areas that
should be included mental health is one
of them
it's been very hard to make this a
public health issue
but it has to be because we have to have
surveillance
systems for mental health that we know
who requires treatment
and how to proceed the other thing is
i think public health should be taking a
lead
on actually looking on health outcomes
by the approach with clinical medicine
in this country we
are satisfied to reward people on the
basis of process
so how many
uh
tests are done for this or that and
how many pap smears and so forth rather
than on outcome
and it always surprises people to know
we spend twice as much per capita as any
place else and yet we're not in the top
5 or 10 or 15 or 20 countries when it
comes to health outcomes so that's one
problem
number two
i think we simply have to re-look at
what's the science the technology
the uh
skills that are needed at cdc to keep it
at the cutting edge
of public health
they've taken a step by having a person
from hhs
now take a month to look at cdc and come
up with suggestions
but we all know
that things have become so political in
this country that half the country will
not accept what comes from inside hhs to
cdc
and i think we need an outside group
looking at the things i just mentioned
of technology skills and so forth and i
would like to see the national academy
of medicine do such a study number
three
i think that cdc should have a series
of conferences
with states
counties
cities
tribes
and
ask the question
how do we get the approach to public
health in this country as seamless as it
was 40 years ago
because 40 years ago we had cdc had no
more authority they could not go in to a
state and investigate an out
an uh
income problem
and they could not decide on who would
do what in the state they always had to
ask for an invitation but it worked
and why did it work because there was
trust
and trust is the glue that keeps a
coalition together
so we can get back to that but it's
going to require a series of meetings
with all of the people involved
it's a different time when i was in the
health department in colorado
the health director in colorado had been
there 30 years that doesn't happen
anymore people are there for two years
and they change as soon as the governor
changes
the same thing at cdc i was cdc director
under both carter and reagan
that that you can't see that happening
again
but that's the next thing that cdc has
to do is figure out how to make a
seamless approach to this and the last
thing i think they need
to get some outside consultation on
communications
how
would it be best for health workers
around the country for instance cdc puts
out the morbidity mortality weekly
report
each week they could send this to all
health officers the night before
with a brief on what are the
complications to expect the next day so
everybody's looking at the same material
so there are things that could be done
to
improve and help cdc at this time it's
critical that we have a cdc
yeah i no
the cdc is essential
uh for this country and and and globally
uh because of its global role as well uh
so you alluded to trust uh in in the
centers for disease control and
prevention
and you alluded to trust between
institutions you know between the cdc
and the states etc but there's a broader
um unfortunate problem of public trust
in cdc and it has been measured and it
has declined
there was another period where the trust
in cdc was dented a bit
uh which was around the swine flu
vaccine program in 1990 1976
where you know there was this
alarm for a potential pandemic or a
large outbreak there was a vaccine
program rolled out there were some
adverse events associated with the
vaccine program with the vaccine
uh you know related to guillain-barre
syndrome which turned out to be
true but not at a level uh where
perhaps it changed the risk benefit risk
but there was you know some lessons for
communications and policy etc and i'm
describing it not for you obviously you
know this by heart i'm just setting
stage the stage for
those of us who were doing other things
uh at that time
like being in kindergarten
so
i'm not that young but you know our
audience is
but but um
sort of going back to sort of that
period
sort of in in that context a context but
also
beyond that
any lessons on restoring public trust in
the cdc
well
you're you're right to point out my age
because i was actually involved in that
and i attended the fir dave censor was
the director of cdc and i attended the
very first meeting he ever had on this
with the advisory committee on
immunization practices
it was an emergency meeting on a
saturday
and what was presented was
three things have happened we have a new
virus
number two we have evidence of human to
human spread fort dix new jersey
and number three there is no immunity in
the population
those three things had never happened
before without resulting in a pandemic
and so it wasn't difficult for the group
to say there's going to be a pandemic
the discussion though revolved around do
we we have to make vaccine do we store
the vaccine in refrigerators or do we
store it in people
well if you store it in refrigerators we
know from experience that a flu outbreak
can go across this country in two weeks
time
if you vaccinate someone with a vaccine
it may take two weeks for them to get
immunity
so there's really no way that you can
justify waiting until you have spread of
the virus before you start vaccinating
that's why there was a decision on
vaccinating
it was not a decision made in isolation
sensor did not even take a vote
of the committee that day and i asked
him afterwards why didn't you and he
said because this is going to be a
political problem
and he said i need to absorb it rather
than have the committee absorb it
but it went all the way to the oval
office
and in the oval office with president
ford
with
censor presenting what we knew
they had in the group salk and sabin and
some of the best virologists of the day
and they all told ford this was the
thing to do
then as soon as we ran into the first
cases of guillain-barre
suddenly people started jumping ship
and eventually it was only dave censor
who was being blamed for what had
happened
the program was stopped because of dion
beret
and censor was fired by uh
joseph califano
actually not by califano but by his
deputy
and so that's how
difficult the political situation is was
at that time but you know cdc did not
lose its credibility
and therefore even though there was some
reduction in the glue of trust
it all came back again
and uh
particularly with legionnaires disease
and the solving of that problem that uh
the trust came back at the present time
the trust trust factor is
really important
because
i see public health people not trusting
each other
i see
the public not trusting public health
and
30 years ago i gave a talk
at
cdc and i was talking about how there
are people who like gandhi
did
the right things but we don't know about
them in history
but i said there are also institutions
that become ghandian institutions and
that cdc was one of them
but that reputation doesn't go on into
the future it has to be earned every day
and that's the challenge of cdc right
now is to earn that reputation back
every day and i think it can be done
interesting so so we now i'm taking some
questions uh from the audience and those
of you who are listening in
please feel free to add your questions
uh so i already have a few questions and
the first one is you know will you
please compare the eradication of
smallpox to the effort uh to eradicate
uh the guinea worm disease
uh which was um you know uh which has
been described et cetera including uh
you know the book by don hopkins and
ernesto ruiz tiben uh i know that you
have been engaged with uh both
individuals and institutions like the
carter center who have been at the you
know forefront of the program
so
any any any lessons that
uh translated and any
lessons that did not translate or
transfer between the smallpox program
and the
the
the guinea worm disease program
first i think all nine lessons do in
fact transfer but guinea worm had
some problems and barriers that smallpox
didn't with smallpox
it was very hard to keep cases hidden
because the disease was on the face and
the hands
and
so people deliberately would hide cases
but it was hard difficult with guinea
worm
the disease wasn't even known in the
capital cities it wasn't even known
where you had the health department
and i think nigeria turns out to be a
good example of that that they were
reporting five or six thousand cases of
guinea worm a year well that didn't seem
like a very big problem
but there was a one-time survey done
in nigeria that showed at one point in
time almost 700
000 cases of guinea worm
and for those 700 000 people it was hard
to go to school it was hard to work in
the field i mean this really did cause a
change in lifestyle but
ministry of health didn't know about
this but with that survey in nigeria the
president of nigeria president babangida
was so surprised by that result he put
up a million dollars in nigerian money
that day
for guinea worm eradication so it shows
the need for political support and how
do you get that kind of political
support
they've also run into a problem of
course with animals and particularly
dogs that transmit guinea worm
we knew from the beginning that there
was guinea worm reported in some animals
but it was always it looked like a dead
end not something that went to humans
and now in chad
there's some certain places where a lot
of dogs have guinea worm
i think that this problem is going to be
solved there were only 15 cases of human
guinea worm last year in the entire
world 15.
compare that to the millions that we
used to have
but here's the problem
that we have to evolve faster
than the organism does in small box that
was always clear to me
that
the
approach from the small box virus point
of view and worked for centuries
and now we were evolving faster than the
virus and the virus couldn't keep up we
have to do the same thing with guinea
worm
yeah so you alluded to
you know animal reservoirs etc and sort
of when when you do these
table top exercises and when diseases
are evaluated
uh for
you know potential for eradication and a
big no-no not another not an absolute
no-no but a big no-no is a
existence of a human a new human
non-human sorry
um reservoir
uh
but you know look we have been making
investments in one health
uh we have we are better at
um sort of measuring
infection and and pathogens in animals
as well as humans do you think it's time
to be a little bit more audacious
is there room for audacity to say
that this criteria is much softer or
should be softer than than than has been
traditionally um and can we be bold
enough to look at uh diseases that have
animal reservoirs uh for potential
elimination or eradication
absolutely i mean the when you look at
the last 30 diseases
that have come unexpectedly to our
attention
75 percent of them involve an animal or
a vector
and yet
we do not do animal and human
surveillance together at cdc or who
until there's a specific problem and
then we do ad-hoc
animal surveillance
so we really have to figure out how to
get the one world approach on
surveillance
there
i haven't looked at this for some years
but i think there's only one place in
the world that actually has
what we used to call a class 4 lab for
animals in a class 4 lab for humans in
the same city and that's winnipeg
canada
and it was by accident i mean two people
that were interested it wasn't
part of a big plan so we haven't
approached this as a unit in the past
and we have to from now on
yeah and so um
a couple of
questions from
additional questions a few other
questions from the audience and one i
think is from a former
cdc
person
if i if i recognize the name correctly
and they ask you know when will the cdc
have a long-term
emergency response division a fixed team
of professionals who are assigned to erd
full-time obviously there is some
capacity in some
organizational structures that are
activated that are semi-permanent but i
think they're talking about something
more permanent more focused and with
dedicated resources
interesting thing here assad is we had
that
in the early 1980s
and people don't know that but we had a
program at cdc
where we looked at each organism and
asked the question
what would we do if we were trying to
use this offensively
and therefore what do we need to do to
come up with the defense
this was with cdc
and the fbi with secure phones
phones
secure rooms
and 24
hour a day
people on call
in order to be able to look at
a particular problem
yeah i was so pleased what was what was
happening with this
when i left this was presented
to the
new director
and his response was oh this will never
happen and he closed on the program
overnight
so
this was in cdc's history and it has to
now be in cdc
cdc's future
so uh so the next question i'm actually
combining a couple of questions there
uh and when one of the the questionnaire
is one of our
living legends uh jerry friedland
here at yale who was
did some has been doing and has did some
pioneering work
in the early parts and subsequent parts
of the hiv
epidemic
i'm combining a couple of questions
there so
could you please comment on the ongoing
concurrent global pandemics of tb and
hiv
in the context of the rapid covet 19
pandemic
and what lessons can be learned and
especially uh and the related part is
that that in terms of the the role of
the cdc you had just left the cdc
uh when hiv came
to four
in terms of
a
an epidemic and then eventually became a
pandemic so any thoughts on hiv aids
from the early days
and the response to that and then what
are the implications uh of for
of covert 19 and the current situation
on the the these
global pandemics of tb and hiv aids
well as you know thought i'm not smart
enough to answer these questions but
i will give you a top of the head
feeling with
hiv
it took quite some time didn't it before
people
saw this as a global problem
i mean i remember those days in africa
where
medical people
teachers
missionaries were dying faster than they
could be replaced and you just had no
idea where this was going to go
and it had to be seen as a global
problem before we could get global
solutions
will durant used to say
that we will never do things on a global
level unless we fear an alien invasion
and it struck me one day
that we have surrogates for an alien
invasion
and hiv eventually became one of those
surrogates for an alien invasion
and so
i think one of the great things that
george w bush did
was to put huge amounts of money
into a global approach to hiv
and we've got to credit him for having
done that
but we should be very
careful in public health to do other
things
as surrogates for an alien invasion
it's what probably led to smallpox
eradication because everyone knew
smallpox was a threat even if they
hadn't seen it for a while in this
country we had not had a case since 1949
and yet
the u.s participated because they saw
this as a threat to the u.s
not just to other countries
and so that's part of what we need to do
in public health is to show how things
are a threat globally and how they
become a surrogate for an alien invasion
coronavirus
it hurts a lot to see how
we did not respond globally the way we
should have
the agave actually had an approach to
the global program
where they had a lot of buy-in but they
couldn't get the vaccine at first
and much of the enthusiasm then started
disappearing
but we have to again
say
every place we are is both local and
global and that our job
is global health equity
yeah so coming to another question so
why are the public health systems in the
u.s so fragmented
um you know they're obviously state
county and federal levels but there are
different policies in different states
obviously that's part of it as a feature
of the system of governance in this
country it's it's you know
because constitutionally the police
powers of the states
which include quarantine powers and all
sorts of other stuff
resides within the states not at the
federal government level although
there's some uh sort of limited exercise
of that but we could do so
we could align um them better you know
we managed to with the same
constitutional and legal infrastructure
we we
managed to have for example a working
interstate highway system uh public
health remains fragmented um
and and so so any thoughts on that
and as i mentioned before
we did not need more authority
because
we had so many people from cdc
who were actually
working in states
we had so many state people who had
taken part of their training at cdc
that this trust factor was different at
that time
it's become politicized since then
because every state governor has their
own
health advisor now and they they switch
a lot but i think we can get back to
that by figuring out what is required to
make this seamless what do states need
from the federal government to make this
happen
and so i haven't given up on the idea
that we don't need more authority we
need more trust
and perhaps more money and if i can you
know one thing i have heard you say a
few times
if i can and heard you quote dolly
parton a few times that it takes money
to look this cheap uh if i'm
paraphrasing that correctly she said
you'd be surprised how much it cost to
look this yeah exactly
you said it right uh
and so um
and and we don't invest enough uh uh you
know there are high returns on
investment
uh on
public health and we still don't take as
a country and as a world don't take the
rational decision of investing uh in in
public health
so in terms of you know we talked about
bioterrorism etc and there's a direct
question from the audience
which says like should the smallpox
virus in the in the two labs in atlanta
and moscow be destroyed and and you know
i i would say that that's a naive
assumption if i may that it is only in
two labs uh they are undeclared uh but
but confirmed
uh reserves correct me if i'm my
interpretation is incorrect but still
it's limited
um
sort of
places where where the virus exists uh
do you think it's too big a threat uh to
uh
have have the virus even present in
those two places or other places as well
so one has to look at
what is the threat if we would
unilaterally destroy
smallpox virus in this country
and
the vaccine is not made from the virus
so we don't need the virus in order to
make vaccine a vaccine is a a a
different virus
it's hard to see any advantage to
keeping the virus because
we have we now have
the
genetic code of every strain of smallpox
virus
and
we know that it's probably possible to
recreate this if someone wanted to i see
no advantage for keeping the virus in
either place
and i see
no advantage to keeping it in this
country if russia refuses to destroy
theirs
so uh
i would say we should destroy our virus
because i can't see any advantage to
having it
okay
um so there's another question and i'll
take the liberty of sort of modifying it
a little bit
um
how do you see the role of wh so uh you
know in in conjunction with cdc but also
as a
as an entity that needs to evolve with
the public health threats
how do you see the role of who going
forward
i always tell people who is absolutely
essential if we didn't have it we'd have
to create it
and so the real question is how do we
improve it
and
unfortunately the united states was
involved in making it as weak as it is
because when it was created
we insisted on strong regional offices
because we were trying to protect pablo
and so the regional offices are strong
enough they can undermine geneva anytime
they want to and apparently they often
want to
and so with ebola in 2016
that the first
big fight was between w.h.o geneva and
who afro
on who's in charge the one thing they
agreed on don't call ncdc
and so this is a problem because
we made who weaker than it needed to be
then what do we do we give them a board
of directors of 193
ministers of health
and there's no one that would accept a
job at a company in the united states
with a board of directors of 193 195
people
and third
we joined the course every year telling
them to reduce their budget
and that's where the dolly parton quote
comes in
that we
i said we will finally learn how much it
costs to look this cheap and i think
2014
in africa with ebola we got our answer
and we need to support who so it has the
same sort of resources
and abilities and technology that the
world needs to have a strong
public health institution
absolutely right and i think as we will
look back on 2020
we will finally account for the
consequences of the us pulling out and
being antagonistic towards who so you
referred to kovacs or you alluded to
covax that's the system that was created
to provide vaccines there were no takers
uh you know initially
they didn't have the money and they
didn't have the backing from the from
big countries like the us who were going
uh
you know who were working against the
interests of kovacs and who and so that
that gap
created uh you know such
the gap in interest and funding and
effort
created such vulnerabilities and and i
would submit that we are still paying
the price in terms of increased risk of
variance etc um
so
you know
one of my colleague is asking that there
are a lot of stories of smallpox
eradication that includes
uh you know the stories from specific
countries somalia for example comes up a
few times um
as one of the
last places uh with smallpox
uh and and and india was you know part
of the story of of polio and pakistan
and afghanistan and and nigeria etc so
what are the implications of global
health governance of outbreaks and
relationships between countries and
international bodies
because yesterday even if you set aside
who
afro
there was a sort of a delicate dance
with with the countries and you had
first-hand experience dealing with
countries both from within uh based on
your deployments but but in your who and
cdc roles as well
well the interesting thing was that we
were able to do this with the soviet
union during the cold war
and so in india i actually supervised
some people from the soviet union who in
turn supervised americans
now you can't imagine that happening in
any other structure at that time during
the cold war
but with health we can have objectives
that are much
more important than the political
differences
and so that's what uh who has to keep
emphasizing what we have to keep
emphasizing that we're willing to work
with anybody in order to improve health
yeah and so uh as we wind down and we
had sort of last five minutes uh
uh of our time
um
you know i would love for you to sort of
talk about um you know
about what advice uh would you share
with
early career investigators young
professionals aspiring public health
professionals etc because a lot of them
are
part of our audience students and early
stage faculty and and others
um
and i will share a personal um
anecdote um
when i became the bill feige professor
in my previous job
it was almost funny that that
as if someone had given a form letter to
people who wrote to me to congratulate
and there was one sentence that was very
surprisingly consistent and it was bill
feige is my public health hero
and and it was you know so it's after
the first two or three emails and these
were people i respected
um etc
but so so from that perspective of
someone who has made contributions to
public health who has been witness to a
lot of successes but also a lot of
shortcomings of the public health system
in the u.s and globally
what advice would you give to
aspiring and early stage public health
professionals and scientists
it's a question i like to deal with
actually and
first of all be very careful
about a life plan
because you can have no idea what
opportunities are going to be presented
to you you have no idea what the new
problems are going to be two years from
now
so be careful about
solidifying a life plan number two i
tell the students
that if you go into global health you're
not likely to get rich
but you're also not likely to get
thanked
but if you can get beyond those two
things
it's re very rewarding and i tell them
the story of pearl kendrick
who worked for the michigan health
department in the 1930s
and she developed pertussis vaccine with
another woman working in the health
department
and when she died in 1980
the
dean of the school of public health at
the university of michigan bill
remington gave a eulogy
and he said there are hundreds of
thousands of people
who are alive because of pearl kendrick
and he paused
and then he asked could you name one
[Music]
he said i can't either
and that's why she was never adequately
thanked
but he said she was secure in the
knowledge
of what she was doing
and so i tell students
you won't get rich you won't be thanked
but be secure in the knowledge of what
you are doing
and then i suggest to them that in any
program they go into or any particular
project that they go into to have
three things in mind
number one the science
and huxley
defined science as simply common sense
at its best
so lots of people get afraid of science
these days and you can see what's
happening in this country with
coronavirus people that don't believe
the science
but they all think they have common
sense
and so if you define science as common
sense at its best it makes it palatable
but number two
will durant said
add to the science art
because he said
then you have creative common sense at
its best
and he uses as his example imhotep from
egypt who was a physician and an artist
he designed
the step pyramid and then he had it
built
so he says adding
art to your science gives you that
creativity
but there's a third thing
and that is
to add a moral compass
and roger bacon is the example i use
from 700 years ago
when the pope asked him for a
summary of science
and bacon worked a long time on that
summary
and then if decided it's too long
and so he did a summary of the summary
finally he did a summary of the summary
of the summer that went to the pope
now i've not looked at this for decades
but there were three things that came to
mind for me number one
he was absolutely enthusiastic about
science
he predicted
planes
submarines
and cars
he predicted telescopes this is 700
years ago
so he was very excited about it
and
number two what i recall
is that after talking about the
possibilities of science
he said but science has no moral compass
so you have to create
scientists with a moral compass
and the third thing
and this is what makes me think the pope
never actually read it
he said the church is doing nothing
to help them
to provide a moral compass
so
here we are still today get the science
right add art get a moral compass and
put those three things together and now
you have moral creative common sense at
its best that's the shortest description
i can make of what it should be like to
go into global health
thank you really appreciate that thank
you for joining us today thanks for all
your passion wisdom
uh and moral leadership uh in global
health for for many decades
thank you to the audience who joined us
today
we are hoping to
to have our fall season for the
conversation series in person or at
least hybrid so stay tuned we have a lot
of exciting guests lined up uh and uh
look forward to seeing you there even if
we do it in person those of you who join
from around the country and and from
various parts of the world
you should be able to follow us online
as well even at that time so thank you
everyone and especially dr feige
thank you